by now you've probably heard of or seen
the video showing 17 year old laQuan
McDonald being shot 16 times by a police
officer over a year ago in Chicago but
why are we just seeing the video now
because there was a cover-up here's how
it went down right after the killing a
police spokesman claimed that McDonald
had been crazed that he slashed tires on
a squad car and damaged a windshield
they said that he refused orders to drop
a knife and lunged at police before the
officer opened fire in self-defense
shooting him in the chest but none of
that happened the newly released dashcam
footage shows McDonald walking away from
officers before being shot just seconds
after the shooter Police Officer Jason
van Dyke arrived on the scene after the
initial shot McDonald falls to the
ground and Van Dyke keeps shooting at
the time the police claimed self-defense
and it looked like the case would soon
be forgotten like most police shootings
across the country but then a
whistleblower informed a local
journalist and lawyer that the police
version wasn't true the two of them put
out a public statement asking the police
to release any video they had of the
incident months later the journalist got
a copy of the official autopsy rather
than just a shot to the chest it showed
that officer van Dyke unloaded his gun
into the victim McDonald was shot in the
scalp neck left chest right chest left
elbow left forearm right arm right hand
right leg and in the back soon after
lawyers for the family obtained the
dashcam video and before they even filed
a lawsuit the city gave the family five
million dollars under the settlement
terms they would keep the video
confidential but another reporter
Brandon Smith wanted to make sure the
public saw what the police were hiding
after he and 15 other journalists had
their freedom of information act request
rejected from the city Smith decided to
sue the police earlier this month he won
the judge ruled that the police had to
release the footage after the ruling but
before the video was actually released
officer van Dyke was charged with
first-degree murder he's the first on
duty Chicago cop to face that charge in
almost 35 years but whether he's can
Vic did remains to be seen the city's
mayor rahm emanuel says van dyke will
face justice and that people need to
come together to quote heal but while
van dyke was the shooter many people in
the chicago police department and a
manuals administration spent a year
trying to cover up what happened so will
they face justice to